Here we are back in our playground file,
entitled, Lesson Two, Optionals.
In the previous example, we accessed the
size property of an image in two steps.
First, we unwrapped the image, and
then we accessed its size property.
A more concise way to
accomplish the same goal
is to access the properties of optional
types using optional chaining.
You'll find that optional chaining
is used widely to access properties
in UI kit.
Here the question mark
unwraps the image optional,
allowing access to its size property.
This is optional chaining.
If we check the type of
the size that's returned,
we see that optional chaining returns
a variable that's also an optional.
Because this size variable
is itself an optional,
even if this image property is nil
there's no risk of a compiler error.
But then, of course,
to use the image size variable we
need to safely unwrap it as well.
So when you see Optional Chaining
in action, it looks like this.
This statement is actually
unwrapping two Optionals.
The question mark is
unwrapping the image Optional.
And the if let construction is
unwrapping the size Optional.
When you look at the two
methods together,
you can see that optional chaining
is slightly more concise.
Let's go through one
more example together.
Let's say we have a class called animal.
And that animal class has
a property called tail.
The tail property is an optional.
Not all animals have tails.
Here will instantiate an animal, Lenny.
He's a lemur.
With a 12 centimeter tail.
Just like with UI image view.
We can use optional chaining to access
a property of an optional type, like so.
Over here in the sidebar we can see that
Lenny's tail is twelve centimeters long.
But if we encounter an animal with
no tail like Gilbert the gorilla,
the program won't crash.
We've safely unwrapped our optionals and
handled the nil case.